[Music]
there's something satisfying about
watching a horror film that's so bad
it's good
if you're in the mood for gratuitous
gore cheesy dialogue and hours of jump
scares
these horror films are the perfect way
to indulge in a guilty pleasure
the premise of the first final
destination movie was actually pretty
clever
a group of friends dodge a freak
accident and they start feeling grateful
that they just evaded their demise
only to die one by one as death comes to
claim its prize
and if you've ever seen a final
destination film you've probably picked
up at least one irrational phobia about
perishing in a statistically improbable
way
there are a grand total of five films in
the franchise with similar plots
and as far as guilty pleasures go they
don't get any guiltier than the fourth
installment
the final destination after nick
o'bannon and his friends narrowly cheat
death by escaping from a stadium just
before disaster strikes
they soon find that their fate is
already sealed and back in 2009
with deadly objects flying at theater
audiences in 3d
the eye-popping visuals took this film
over the top when it came to gore
so the next time you decide to give the
final destination a go
you'll be simultaneously fascinated and
disgusted by the increasingly absurd
ways in which the film
sends these characters to their doom
right off the bat the gimmicky title of
13 ghosts tips you off about the kind of
film you're about to watch
cyrus a ghost hunter on a quest to
capture a spirit known as the juggernaut
is killed when his team finally manages
to catch the ghost
his assistant dennis manages to make it
out alive
and when cyrus's nephew arthur learns
that he's inherited cyrus's mansion
dennis offers to show him around but
there's a catch
arthur has also inherited all of the
ghosts that come with it
they were held captive by spells that
cyrus had cast
but cyrus's lawyer accidentally seals
the house shut and releases all the
ghosts
kicking off a wild paranormal battle
[Music]
it's time to leave i'll take your word
for it
when it comes to visual and sound
effects this film goes all
out it's a loud flashy immersive
experience and while it might be too
intense for some viewers there's
something admirable about it
this film is light on actual scares but
you'll find yourself sticking around
just to find out the significance of the
mysterious 13th ghost
have you ever gotten lost in a sketchy
area while on your way to an unfamiliar
destination
if you've got a poor sense of direction
you'll probably find yourself
sympathizing with the characters in
wrong turn
after chris takes an ill-fated
unintentional detour away from his
intended route
he ends up crashing right into an suv
whose passengers had their road trip
ruined when their tires blew out
everyone escapes the accident mostly
unscathed but now they've got to figure
out where they are
and how they're going to get back to
civilization as it turns out they may
have wandered into a deadly trap that
they can't escape
wrong turn isn't exactly a sophisticated
horror film
and this becomes obvious as soon as the
audience is introduced to the
cannibalistic hillbilly villains who
feast on unsuspecting road trippers
it's a senseless slasher gore-fest but
the premise is frightening and
suspenseful enough that you won't want
to chance a long drive without your
trusty gps app
when it comes to guilty pleasure b
movies anaconda hits all the right notes
it's a 90's horror film about a
documentary crew getting roped into the
hunt for a legendary giant snake
starring jennifer lopez ice cube and
owen wilson
when this group of filmmakers arrives in
the amazon they have every intention of
making a movie about an elusive
indigenous tribe but then a snake hunter
forces them to join him on his own
mission
capturing a massive anaconda that he's
been trying to track down
if you like monster movies and you're
looking for some corny cinematic fun
no film fits the bill quite like
anaconda this is a movie that knows just
how silly it is
in one scene the snake actually screams
based on the 1953 film house of wax this
2005 reboot follows a group of teenagers
who are lured into a strange wax museum
at a town in the middle of nowhere but
these aren't your ordinary wax figures
as the creepy twins who run the wax
museum have a rather unorthodox method
for creating their displays
the crew soon discovers that the wax
figures look so realistic because
they're molded around the bodies of
other victims who
ended up trapped there and now it looks
like they're about to be next
as far as guilty pleasure films go this
movie checks all the boxes
it's got characters that can't help but
make the worst possible decision at any
given moment
a genuinely creepy setting and a razzy
nomination for worst picture
that's about right this loose remake of
the 1980 horror film prom night fails to
live up to its predecessor which to be
fair
wasn't meant to be more than a mildly
entertaining slasher flick in the first
place
britney snow stars as donna the popular
teen queen with a dark past
her entire family was murdered by her
stalker a teacher who became so obsessed
with her that he was willing to kill
anyone who stood in the way
but now he's escaped from prison just in
time for donna's prom night
and after all these years he hasn't
forgotten about her
so tell me what color is your dress
prom night is so melodramatic that it
often slips into unintentional comedy
and donna's stalker somehow manages to
be everywhere at once
this isn't a film that demands critical
thought or serious analysis from its
audience
the 1993 horror comedy leprechaun is one
of the most bizarre slasher films of all
time
and it follows the exploits of an evil
leprechaun who goes after the man that
stole his pot of gold
while the antagonist is entertaining
enough very little makes sense about the
plot which involves the leprechaun
setting bear traps
chasing people down in a go-kart and
sneaking into a nursing home
to be fair the crew behind leprechaun
wasn't exactly shooting for an academy
award
what more could you expect from a film
that was reportedly inspired by lucky
charms commercials
what the hell are you i'm a leprechaun
meteor
shockingly this film ended up spawning
five sequels
so you can easily embark on a guilty
pleasure leprechaun marathon
piranha 3d kicks off during spring break
at lake victoria where tourists are
sunbathing
and partying after an earthquake
countless prehistoric piranhas emerge
from a crevice at the bottom of the lake
when a man's mutilated body is found in
the water the local authorities decide
to keep the area open for beachgoers to
avoid scaring off tourists but when the
piranhas start a full-blown feeding
frenzy
the scene at this carefree summer camp
quickly turns into a bloodbath
he'll have fun spotting a few familiar
faces in the midst of the chaos
including actors like adam scott richard
dreyfuss and christopher lloyd who are
clearly having a lot of fun hamming it
up
this particular piranha
vanished off the face of the earth more
than two
million years ago this reimagining of
the 1982 film this house on sorority row
explores what happens when a prank goes
dead wrong a group of sorority sisters
help one of their friends pull a prank
on her boyfriend
and they accidentally end up killing her
in the process after hiding her body
everyone involved agrees that they will
never say a word about it to anyone
but as graduation day approaches they
find out that someone is on to them
and now they're all in trouble the
characters in sorority row
are so unapologetically insufferable
that you won't exactly pity them as
they're picked off one by one
all of the worst cliches and stereotypes
about greek life are on full display
here
but it's mindless slash or fun and it's
easy to get caught up in the silly plot
for an hour and a half
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more
looper videos about horror movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one